nadie está en la casa mientras que pedro
está en la escuela la distancia que
separa la casa de la escuela es de 6 km
ellos empiezan a viajar hacia la
dirección del otro al mismo tiempo si
nadie va caminando a una velocidad de
3.5 kilómetros por hora y pedro va
caminando a una velocidad de 6
kilómetros por hora cuando se
encontrarán ya qué distancia estarán de
la casa cuando se encuentren y bueno
vamos a suponer que aquí tenemos a nadie
aquí tenemos a pedro la distancia entre
la casa y la escuela son 6 kilómetros y
van en dirección el uno al otro por lo
tanto nadie va a una velocidad de 3.5
kilómetros por hora km nada más grande'
kilómetros por hora mientras que pedro
va a una velocidad de 6 kilómetros por
hora 6 kilómetros programa y bueno va
hacia acá ahora date cuenta que ellos se
van a interceptar en algún punto por lo
tanto vamos a poner al punto donde se va
a interceptar justo por aquí voy a decir
que aquí semana interceptar y bueno date
cuenta que como pedro va
va a recorrer más distancia de lo que va
a recorrer nadie por lo tanto se va a
interceptar en este punto y ahora sí
vamos a definir a x como la distancia
que hay de la casa al punto de decir
detectan que de hecho es una de las
cosas que me preguntan la distancia de
la casa al punto donde se intersectan
esta va a ser equis y bueno cómo puedo
saber la otra distancia y la distancia
que recorre pedro para no hacernos más
bolas y meter una nueva variable voy a
decir que esto es 6 - x perfecto aquí ya
tengo que la distancia que recorre nadie
es x mientras que la distancia que
recorre pedro es 6 menos x es decir 6
kilómetros menos la distancia que
recorre nadie ahora bien para resolver
este problema lo que voy a usar es una
fórmula que ya hemos visto varias veces
y está muy metida en nuestros vídeos de
física está fórmula dice que la
distancia es igual a la velocidad por el
tiempo o la distancia igual a la rapidez
por el tiempo si utilizo esta fórmula
para nadie me va a quedar que x es igual
a 3.5 portem la distancia que recorre
nadie es x la velocidad a la que va
nadie es 3.5 kilos
y el tiempo esté bien ahora hagamos lo
mismo para pedro pedro va a recorrer una
distancia de 6 x kilómetros y por la
fórmula esto va a ser igual a la
velocidad que son 6 kilómetros por hora
por el tiempo pero aquí hay algo muy
importante que quiero que te des cuenta
tanto nadie como pedro se van a
encontrar al mismo tiempo porque justo
esto es lo que me dice el problema que
salen en el mismo momento y por lo tanto
va a pasar el mismo tiempo para que se
encuentren y ahora ya tengo dos
ecuaciones con dos incógnitas y ya puedo
resolver este problema qué te parece si
de esta ecuación sustituyó el valor de x
en nuestra segunda ecuación x es igual a
3.5 tm y en lugar de x en esta ecuación
voy a escribir 3.5 temas y que me va a
quedar que 6 - x pero x vale 3.5 t'aime
entonces 6 menos 3.5 tm esto tiene que
ser igual a 6 t georges y vamos a
resolver para el tiempo ya no está tan
difícil si yo paso a esto del otro lado
me va a quedar que 6 es igual a 6 de 3.5
tm 6 temas 3.5 tm es lo mismo
9.5 t y ahora voy a dividir todo entre
9.5 para despejar el tiempo y me queda
que el tiempo es igual a 6 entre 9.5
pero bueno 9.5 lo puedo ver como un
quebrado esto es lo mismo que en 19
medios entonces me quedarían 6 entre 19
medios 9.5 lo mismo que 19 medios y
ahora sí sí yo divido un número entre un
quebrado es lo mismo que multiplicar ese
mismo número por el recíproco de este
quebrado y me va a quedar 6 por 2 entre
19 lo cual me da 12 entre 1912 entre 19
horas es decir que el tiempo en el que
se van a encontrar los dos es 12 entre
19 horas ahora bien tanto nadie como
pedro se van a interceptar en un punto y
bueno ya es bien fácil sacar a x porque
que es va a ser igual a 3.5 por el
tiempo pero ya sé cuánto vale el tiempo
por ciento 3.5 es lo mismo que siete
medios siete medios lo voy a multiplicar
por el tiempo pero el tiempo en el cual
se encuentran los dos es 12 entre 19 por
lo tanto me va a quedar
x es igual y voy a simplificar aquí un
poco a 7 por 6 lo cual es 42 42 entre 19
42 entre 19 kilómetros y esto estaba
dado en horas y por lo tanto ya tengo la
respuesta de este problema ellos se van
a encontrar en un tiempo de 2 entre 19
horas mientras que se van a interceptar
a una distancia de 42 entre 10 y 9
kilómetros de la casa así que vamos a
seguir hablando de pedro y vamos a ver
otro problema que tenga que ver con
pedro pedro compró algunas de sus
libretas para clases en el supermercado
a un precio de 2.25 pesos cada una y
otras de sus libretas las compro en una
papelería a un precio de dos pesos cada
una sin dotarse gasto en ambos lugares
la misma cantidad de dinero y compro 17
libretas en total cuantas libretas
compró pedro en cada lugar así que vamos
a empezar a definir variables voy a
decir que ese es la cantidad de libretas
que compró en el supermercado y voy a
decir que r es igual a la cantidad de
libretas que compro en la
papelería que compró en la papelería
bueno lo primero que voy a hacer es
escribir ecuaciones con ese hierro y la
primera que sé es que es más r tiene que
ser igual a 17 pedro cumplió 17 libretas
en total para todo el año escolar por lo
tanto s más r
debe ser 17 s más r debe de ser igual a
17 esto es el primer dato que me dan y
bueno ya está escrito en una ecuación
ahora también me dan el dato de que
pedro gastó en la misma cantidad de
dinero en ambos lugares es decir la
cantidad de dinero que gastó en el
supermercado al comprar las libretas es
exactamente igual que la cantidad de
dinero que gastó en la papelería al
comprar las libretas eso lo puedo poner
de la siguiente manera como hablo de que
tienen la misma cantidad de dinero pues
entonces me quedarían que la cantidad de
libretas que compro en el supermercado
por el precio que costaba cada una de
las libretas es decir 2.25 por la
cantidad de libretas que comprueben
supermercado es decir ese esto es lo que
se gastó en el supermercado esto me
dicen que es exactamente igual a la
cantidad de dinero que se
en las libretas que compró en la
papelería es decir voy a multiplicar la
cantidad de libretas que compre una
papelería por el precio que gasto en la
papelería que son dos pesos por lo tanto
me quedarían dos por r esto es lo que se
gastó en la papelería al comprar sus
libretas muy bien entonces tengo que
2.25 s es igual a 20 y ya está bien
fácil resolver este problema porque
entonces puedo sustituir ya sea ese o
arn en mi primera ecuación y para esto
voy a despejar aún a estas dos variables
creo que es más fácil despejar a r por
lo tanto de esta ecuación de aquí abajo
voy a despejar a r para sustituirla en
el valor de arriba entonces para
despejar a r lo que tengo que hacer es
dividir 2.25 entre 2 me va a quedar que
2.25 entre 2 por s esto tiene que ser
igual a r muy bien y ya con este valor
de eren ahora lo tuve en cds substituir
el valor de r
mi primera ecuación es decir voy a meter
este valor aquí y que me va a quedar que
s más r pero en lugar de eren recuerda
que voy a poner 2.25 entre 2 por ese
entonces me va a quedar ese 2.25 entre 2
por s esto tiene que ser igual a 17 esto
tiene que ser igual a 17 días sustituye
el valor de r que me dice mi segunda
ecuación ahora uno por s
es lo mismo que dos medios por ese
entonces en lugar de s voy a escribir
dos medios de s para que sea mucho más
fácil hacer esta operación dos medios de
s más 2.25 entre dos por s cuando es
esto pues esto es lo mismo que 4.25
entre dos por s y esto tiene que ser
igual a 17 georges y despejando de aquí
a ese que me va a quedar para
estructurarse es pasar a este quebrado a
esta fracción del otro lado
multiplicando la por su recíproco es
decir 2 entre 4.25 de tal manera que del
lado izquierdo todo esto se va y me
queda solamente que s es igual a 17 por
2 lo cual es 34 entre
4.25 y habrá que hacer esta operación
bueno para no hacer toda la división lo
que voy a hacer es pera 4.25 como cuatro
enteros un cuarto 4.25 cuatro enteros un
cuarto que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que cuatro por cuatro 16 más 117 cuartos
y bueno de igual manera lo que voy a
hacer es multiplicar pues recíproco no
va a quedar 34 por 4 entre 17 pero qué
creés 34 y 17 se pueden simplificar aquí
se van aquí se van y me queda solamente
2 por 4 lo cual es 8 es decir que la
cantidad de libretas que compró este
pedro en el supermercado es 8 y por lo
tanto ya podemos saber cuántas libretas
compró en la papelería si de esta misma
ecuación de una manera rápida de aquí
despejó ayer me va a quedar que r es
igual a 9 entonces también ya resolví
este problema así que en lo que resta de
vídeo vamos a resolver otro problema más
que tenga que ver también con pedro y en
esta ocasión también con nadie y dice
pedro está viendo a los cerdos ya las
gallinas en la granja pedro tenía una
granja y nadie por su parte está dentro
de la casa y no puede
a los animales entonces a pedro se le
ocurre un acertijo le dice a nadie que
en total hay 13 cabezas de animales y 36
patas de animales y le preguntan cuántos
cerdos hay la granja y cuantas gallinas
hay en la granja entonces vamos a
definir variables se ap la cantidad de
cerdos y se hace la cantidad de gallinas
lo primero que sabemos es que p más se
tiene que ser igual a 13 porque porque
cada cerdo tiene una cabeza y cada
gallina tiene una cabeza y si tenemos 13
cabezas en total por lo tanto se tiene
que ser igual a 13 bueno esto es por una
parte ahora date cuenta que cada cerdo
tiene cuatro patas mientras que cada
gallina tiene solamente dos patas por lo
tanto la cantidad de patas que tiene un
cerdo por la cantidad de cerdos más la
cantidad de patas que tiene una gallina
por la cantidad de gallinas esto tiene
que ser igual a la cantidad de patas que
hay en total es decir 36 y es aquí donde
radica la idea del acertijo de este
pedro porque se dio cuenta que cada uno
de los cerdos tiene solamente cuatro
patas y cada una de las gallinas
solamente tiene dos patas
y bueno para resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones lo voy a resolver por su me
resta entonces voy a multiplicar por dos
la primera ecuación completa y nos va a
quedar 2pm más 12 esto es igual a 26 y
ahora si yo agarro la primera ecuación y
a esta ecuación le restó la segunda
ecuación la segunda ecuación que acaba
de obtener ya voy a obtener una manera
muy sencilla el valor de p es decir
cuántos cerdos tengo y para esto
entonces lo que voy a hacer es restar de
la primera ecuación dos veces la segunda
ecuación y entonces todos estos se
convierten en menos y que me va a quedar
4pm nudos p2p 12 menos 12 pues estos dos
se dan se cancelan y solamente me
quedaría 36 menos 26 lo cual es 10 y ya
está muy fácil esto vale 5 si paso
dividiendo el 2 me va a quedar que la
cantidad de cerdos es igual a 5 y una
vez que ya tengo la cantidad de cerdos
sacar la cantidad de gallinas ya es muy
sencillo porque obtengo que 5 se es
igual a 13 y si de aquí paso el 5 del
otro lado con un signo contrario me
queda que la cantidad de gallinas es
igual a 8 y esto gracias al método de
suma y resta y fíjate que tienen toda la
lógica
porque si yo sumo 85 me va a dar 13 y
por otra parte cuatro patas porcinas por
la cantidad de cerdos que tenemos es 4
por 5 lo cual me daría 20 y después dos
patas avícolas por la cantidad de
gallinas que tengo me quedaría 28 por 2
16 2016 es 36
tenemos 36 patas de animales en total
por lo tanto en la granja del buen pedro
había 5 cerdos y 8 gallinas